Change lives. Change organizations. Change the world.
Where the GSB is going to have the biggest impact is changing the organizations I’m going to work with.
I used to think a lot of leadership as having
charisma and strong will
and that’s helpful but far from sufficient.
It’s really about empathy and understanding the people you’re trying to lead.
Organizations need individuals who take initiative, who are creative, who can problem solve.
Change organizations
The world in which our students are going to manage
is changing at an increasingly rapid rate.
We equip our students with the ability to understand the global context of management.
We require that every single student go to a country where they did not grown up and where they have not had significant work experience.
It helps you get out of the classroom and into the real world,
into a room where somebody who’s an expert in the field and actually be able to understand how you build an oil-well in Brazil,
how you build a new company in Brazil.  That’s experience that you can’t get in the classroom.
You don’t only get what you should do
but also you get ideas on how to do it
and you learn what kind of real-life impact you can have on people and organizations.
No matter how much we talk about a country, it’s a completely different thing to actually come to a country.
I was a leader on a global study trip to Kenya and Rwanda.
We met with President Kegami, the President of Rwanda,
and Daniel arap Moi, the former President of Kenya.
We met the head of marketing of Red Bull.
A meeting with Bay and Capital.
We're meeting with Shanda,
the best streaming company in China.
CEOs of Equity Bank Kenya Airways.
Today we are meeting with the Ministry of Industry and Commerce.
And a really modern person in the whole government structure.
He’s also Stanford GSB alum.
Why I think the GSB is an amazing environment,
it is so people centric in its approach.
It was a wonderful experience of two years.
Number one in some of the experiences that I’ve had in life.
Some of the lessons learned from GSB alums were amazing
with key takeaways that they took  from Stanford
and how they’re able to implement them.
I mean, change organizations, the way I’m doing it
is to be a female at this role at this level.
To have the confidence to speak my voice.
Tonight we’ll visit a lot of GS alumni in Shanghai from all industries.
It seemed nice and they were very
warm-hearted to give us great career advice.
We require that on every study trip
at least one faculty member joins the students.
When the faculty come on these trips
we develop that first-hand knowledge
about these international economies.
See the way local business leaders are responding
to the particular environment they find themselves in.
We can bring that experience directly into the
classroom and say, “Look we’ve spoken with
these business leaders.”
The professors offer insights that help
you quickly get to sort of the root issues of we’re looking at.
It really helps learning experience.
Change organizations.
The more you hear from different people
about how they do things, what they think’s important,
you begin to get a sense of what is my leadership style,
what are the things that resonate with me.
We just get all the opportunities that are out there.
Guess what, at 28, 29, you can come and be a VP,
you can work for the CEO, if the next step for you
is to be in a senior leadership,  and then change organizations.
What I’ve learned here on leadership, on change,
is going to be hugely valuable to me in the next 3 to 5 years
of my career and obviously far beyond that too.